you had a sex scene in Horrible Bosses -
that was edited out and I thought that's
not possible no one edits out a Jennifer
Aniston sex scene that's not possible
no it was possible because it was a well
it was kind of not even the mutual you
know in not good to say it but um it you
know he was in the is in a coma yeah and
I exploit him yeah whilst he's in a coma
so I don't know if you it so it was a
sex scene that was sort of it was it was
I yeah they removed it removed it they
removed it okay but I bet it'll be on
that DVD extras or whatever they do they
yeah it's gonna be in their terrifying
thing to have to shoot by the way
because usually you have as a partner
with you like just sort of be like god
this is hard huh yeah oh yeah this is
hard this is weird but yet they're ready
probably see
you had such an amazing spa vacation
you're talking to two guys we've never
shot sex scenes before we don't know why
I've never shot a sex scene in my life
right well let me explain it to you
usually no you usually have your someone
there but he's just laying there lie in
a car and you have to yeah exactly
this way wave you know let's get that by
myself with that clip you're not coming
back her here no you're invited back
alright it back it's me
you